good morning Millennials
welcome back to the morning toast is to
say the sun is shining in New York
because it's merge day March March March
March March is I mean I'm a motors
burners right where's work it has been
quite a minute since we dropped a merch
launch launched a merge drop yeah and I
feel as if we've made up for lost time
because this drop is [ __ ] premium I
sell ya got koozies we got hats we got
fanny packs we got pop sockets without
flat we have towels oh it's the summer
merch shop it's everything that you need
for summer so many of the things that
people have been requesting I personally
will be getting one of everything meet
you and then once you're done spending
all your money you get this flat broke
fanny pack and then you can write
everyone know that that's why you have
no more money it's very exciting the
merch store will open at the end of this
episode so just feel free to enjoy this
premium episode what a great morning you
have ahead of you because it's like you
just enjoy this premium episode where we
deliver the fast five stories they need
to know before you wake up talk about
any more interests not yet annual and
then you buy your merch and that's like
another 30 minutes to talk to you fellow
toasters like what are you getting how
does this feel size-wise and then the
gun chime it sunshine then you head over
to patreon where you watch my closet or
from yesterday where I got a full revamp
with imagine it done honestly the
reviews are in for the video and people
are loving it like Lisa from imagiknit
Donna's getting so many tips and tricks
for organizing your closet like so many
things that you can buy that'll just
change the game and I saw the video
she's wearing Alison loo hoops so look
she's honest she's in tune with what's
necessary it's a great video and then if
you really want some more content the
Schmitz is out today
yes and it's a very special episode
because Ben's two co-hosts like ditched
him for vacation they took a page out of
Claudia's book they took a page out of
my book and they went on tour they went
on tour he went on tour and now we had
Zach Weinreb and Zach Shapiro Jackie's
husband and Olivia's husband fill in so
it's just like the brother-in-law
episode it'll be coming out today around
3 o'clock and it's it's about the Derby
and winning soccer of course Ben is just
as obsessed with women's soccer as I am
and like I don't know if I told you guys
I'm like infiltrating the team like
Charlie become like the goalie or
something because I spoke to some of the
members like I did with some of them and
then one of their publicist reached out
cuz I said on the show that we wanted to
have the one the toast and
like maybe there will be a USWNT X TMT
crossover coming sometime soon come I'm
gonna have to come out with merge soccer
balls oh my god pleats Lee shin guards
shin guards I'm so excited about this
March launch so just gird your loins
unlimited stock don't worry everyone
will be able to get everything they want
also our sorority sweatshirts are back
in stock which are like bestsellers
bestsellers and if you identify as a
toaster which if you're watching the
show I seen you do it is pertinent to
the situation that you own a store
already smiter because that is the real
toaster in the wild calling like yeah
obviously there's pot there's new pop
sockets there's old pop sockets there's
best sellers had things that people just
always want but like if you are wearing
that sweatshirt you're in the club we
need to hit Ariana Grande and that's
sweatshirt anywhere we can keep
photoshopping it's just as good it's
just as good well that may be a good
segue into into the you think it's time
well I just need a lot to do today let
me to recap below-deck yeah we can
Jackie's now a squeegee girl who does
the both sides I can spiezio who does
the both sides and I'm a chef right so
like I think it's time to deliver the
Fast Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast wow this actually
might be the fastest we've ever done it
I didn't even look at the clock 10:33
I'm not ready okay me neither
let's no more let's definitely talk more
how we could talk about how you have
made so many strides in planning my trip
for Vegas you know better late than ever
now it's all there like what do I pack
for this trip what do I pack for this
chick although it's also interesante is
that I think if I hadn't done my closet
sign yesterday I would be wearing
something completely different you know
this wouldn't be in my line of you I do
and I just feel like that's just an
interesting factoid about the world
that's my day could have been different
you know yeah I mean that's you know you
fart in Japan and someone cries in
America you know yeah and Here I am
crying in the butterfly effect I learned
after that that is what it was called
the butterfly effect it's like if you
you know yeah you know you know Joey you
say it again cuz I don't know it's a
butterfly flaps its wings in Japan which
causes an earthquake somewhere else
that's what I gleaned from everyone
correcting us yeah so if a butterfly
farts okay and flaps his wings the fart
makes sense because it's a really severe
so is the flap yeah yeah it creates but
I was brave of you I would never do that
if I was
when slaves you ate it no no no no no no
I would never flap my arms like I would
rather die okay you're not a butterfly
no no but I could be with these wings
okay now now it's time now that we've
really circled the drain truly okay it's
time for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your moaning Tosa and here
is the first one because Kim Kardashian
is covering the first-ever digital issue
of The Wall Street Journal and she is
talking Kim oh no Kim oh no Kim
Kardashian has opened up about the
kimono shapewear incident in a new Wall
Street Journal interview for a little
refresher on June 25th the keeping up
the cry - Ian star announced a new sheet
brow line called kimono quickly people
expressed concern or over the name
launching the hashtag Kim oh no
sounds like Jackie oh no after
responding to the criticism in a
statement to the New York Times she
announced an Instagram post that she was
changing the name and now she's sharing
her experience throughout the whole
controversy in a cover story for the
publication's first all-digital issue on
Monday July 8th the reality star says
the whole thing was fueled by quote
innocent intentions you would think we
would have obviously thought it through
a little bit deeper she confesses I'm
the first person to say oh okay of
course I can't believe we didn't think
of this I obviously had really innocent
intentions but let's listen and I really
I want to really listen I want to take
it all in I believe that she claims
she's still figuring out what to change
the lines name - but she fully
understands why she has to do it okay
I'm glad she's still figuring it out
because I saw a post me too that said
that the new name was solution where it
didn't say the new name was solution
where it just was captioned solution
where as if it was the name of the brand
right okay and I thought that was - and
I was extremely disappointed me -
because solution where it's like the
category
yeah no it's like shapewear it's the
same yeah no okay I'm glad she did this
interview I don't love this hairstyle
she was rocking at the White House and
now in this Wall Street Journal like the
mom Bob it's really it's a mom but it's
like super curly at the bottom and I'm
just not into it okay I have a few
things to say I got that one I love the
look it's her and Chloe we call
themselves the mom Bob's when they have
this haircut they wore it to that poker
game with Randall Emmett yes no but
where she's never had it so curly
underneath before and it's [ __ ]
animate and too
there was a time in my life when I had
this haircut and I styled it this way
and no one was a bigger champion for it
than you so are you saying you only like
it on me or your liar by the way or
yours haste change
haircuts no neither haircuts look
different on everyone so I'm saying and
by the way you never had it so [ __ ]
bouncy curling under towards your chin
and if you did it was just because you
look like Bree van de Kamp and you know
I'm here for that see that hair carrot
works on Bree van de pack even though
she had it flip on the outside and Kim's
flipping it in towards her chin I just I
don't like it and it's nothing about the
haircut it's just like what is you doing
it makes no sense I personally like it
but you don't I mean I prefer it so much
more than the super long hair like the
cher hair I mean this recent haircut
where she had short straight and then
had like our little high pony I loved
that
super key super cute fresh young New
York mom you know but they're all either
super long or super short like yeah what
happens in the average hair right I
don't know what happened to some layers
and angles huge will you be purchasing
kimono shapewear or whatever it ends up
being called I will not because that's
not something that I like I like the
shapewear that I have I don't have this
slit issue but I but there are many
other items she has the high waisted on
these that we love that I own
high-waisted undies and they're good
enough my bike is for sure but I am
gonna be buying her I don't even want to
say it because like I'm creating
competition for myself but her body
makeup goes back on sale today today I
don't want to I don't want to say it I
think I no no no because we couldn't go
do you think it'll ship for Vegas no no
should we ship it to Vegas or no it
won't ship in time there they're
shipping isn't like [ __ ] immediate you
can get the body foundation my body
shimmer
I'm buddy foundation me too I don't need
more sweat on my legs my legs glisten
you highlight any shimmer like powder
you crush up and I get on there just
three three go go chain I'm gonna do why
don't we just get one of each there's
like one jury although
there's seven there seven I'll do a
light /media what color does MJ wear
that's mine yeah I'd really say fairing
is MJ there I think there I think I'm
gonna go one above fair which is what
there's fair light light / medium medium
I wouldn't like such maybe I do okay
cool okay exciting look I want to get
two tubes what if you get their own
color oh [ __ ] yeah but you know I can't
believe there's not more like issues
with buying makeup on the Internet
I was buying some eyebrow pencil and
there was a coup Brad Brown ello like
how do you know know what color your
eyebrows are yeah yeah I mean you just
know or you watch I'm sitting here
talking about Kylie's and she doesn't
enough tutorials that you can you can
figure it out yeah you just have to find
someone who has similar colors do I need
to do a bit of research on Kim's
Instagram to see what my color is I
could find it yeah what did she say what
colors she wears cuz she's like wait a
nur than me yeah I'm sure she does say
so yeah when she did the video of her
legs I'm sure yeah that whole psoriasis
cover-up was magical magical no I got
like so desperate because I missed out
on the body lotion that I wound up
seeing an ad for Patrick toss body
makeup yes and I ordered it and this is
just the highlight right it's um
I don't know what it's not Foundation
video of it Rosie Rosie and she's like
literally look so skinny I was like
wanting to feed her she'll just so
hungry
well hopefully it makes me look skinny -
um I have it like I would have given it
to you I didn't know that I ordered it
that will be here in time for Vegas okay
so but it's not above three fluid ounces
so you can't bring it on the plane hey
guys checking in back to Vegas oh no no
no no you know it's movie need three
outfits yeah yeah we can do it okay are
you ready for an x-ray which might get
you in the Vegas moon and then let me
think what could possibly get me in the
biggest movie I don't think you'll know
this story but it's gonna get you in the
Vegas moon do do tell so Stu toe La La
Anthony wins $60,000 on a slot machine
amid divorce plans with Carmelo so just
La La Anthony hit the jackpot
the actress 168 thousand dollars at a
slot machine in New Orleans this weekend
right after her rep confirmed that she's
pursuing the next steps to end her
marriage
NBA player Carmelo Anthony I hadn't
heard that part either well they have
been like in the process of getting
divorced for literally 10 years yeah but
like but never confirmed after both game
I didn't think that that was the smoking
gun know that everyone else thought that
it was no I know she was in New Orleans
for the essence festival when she shared
her big win on Instagram her estranged
husband Carmelo was not with her and
Louis seemingly threw shade at him
during the festival she pumped up the
crowd by telling them she didn't care
about a man anymore
while on Carmela's relationship has been
on the rocks for quite some time okay
sad about the marriage
wait but when you wit like is this
community property now you have to give
34 34 thousand dollars to Carmelo
Anthony's gonna have to give 34 thousand
dollars to taxes and then 22 then the
rest 12,000 Carmelo no 17:70 wait this
is like my dream our friend Lauren also
she would she was in Vegas she wasn't
$13,000 at the airport on the way home
when she decided to stay and spend it
all so she makes up like a sweet well so
that's my question if this happened to
you and it's like it's not life-changing
amount of money it's like just a big
hunk of cash you have to pay taxes then
what would you do with it would you save
it would you get tomato you always
wanted or would you just go on a bender
weekend oh I would say that like I'm I'm
quite fiscally responsible and I would
put it in a high-yield bond really yeah
I think I would buy one thing that I've
been dying for so I take a trip yeah
well know what trip is like you could go
through 13 grand on a trip yeah
obviously I'm chartering a plane so like
yeah that's okay take like three grand
buy a purse save the rest if I really
got 68k I would put 30 away fur taxes
and then I only have 38 left and I just
put it in a like a bank account okay
that's like so not exciting it's how
you're gonna have like a better answer
like we can go on a crazy trip I mean I
didn't tell you boy like sweet Margot
anytime we play this game like if you
had X amount of money who would you give
it you what do you think of I give it
five million now oh yes so like spoiler
alert in bluebloods when our favorite
characters like finally realized that
they loved each other it was right after
there was a near-death experience with
the cops so they're right before the
neared nothing spirits are talking about
if you had five million dollars what
would you do and they were doing
a million dollars to charity yeah and
then they have this like near-death
experience or they almost get shot and
she thinks he's dead but it's not and
they hug and they really realize that
they love each other and Jamie whispers
he's like it's been the 5 million on you
damned it was mad cute and like honestly
maybe that's episode television I've
seen in the last 10 years everyone
saying what they would do with the money
what do people say I'm the expenditure
on Murray oh great they would pay off
credit card and then go on a big
vacation I would like read damp okay I
would take like a good amount and like I
want a brand new like makeup okay I want
like no this is what I want I want I
didn't tell her I hate I think I hate my
vanity like the makeup situation it's
like so dirty and I just want like
brand-new makeup with like a marble
mirrored vanity like in my closet like I
need a contractor to come so I can get
all new makeup from like function of
beauty and just like sit with my
brand-new face and just like have clean
I just like my makeup is so dirty right
now I [ __ ] like yelling up everywhere I
feel that too in my corn like that's
such a creative way and you need new
function of beauty well we all know the
frustration bottles on bottles piling up
in your bathroom each one falsely
promising a miracle solution that only
kind of work but what if there was just
one shampoo that could truly do it all
most shredstar brands only address a
single concern like volumizer or
strengthen with function of beauty you
can choose up to five hair goals to add
to your formulation function of beauty
individually formulates every bottle
based on your hair type hair goals and
preferences you select your color and
fragrance and or you can opt for a dye
free and fragrance free the products are
so personalized your name is even
printed on the bottle how freaking cute
so if you want to receive 20% off your
first order redeem and head to function
of beauty.com slash toast and take their
hair profile quiz go to function of
beauty calm slash toast to get 20% off
your custom formula I have truly been in
the market for something like this
everyone knows I'm going through like a
hair crisis we're like I had broken hair
and like damaged hair and my gray hair
for the first time in my life when for
the first 24 years of my life I was just
like that girl with great hair and I
took it for an advantage and now I'm
just like the girl with broken hair who
like carries pomade with her okay that's
what I do so I'm looking for like a
nourishing and I don't want any chemical
so I did fragrance free I did
Jeffrey I want like the most nourishing
conditioning shampoo conditioner I've
been using it for a few weeks now I feel
like it's really working
no it is your hair looks great does it
I'm like so subconscious in my ear no it
looks so great I mean don't be so hard
on yourself really in the words of Jess
Glynne in the words of jessalyn don't be
so hard on yourself
oh is it no or oh dude don't be don't be
so hard on yourself oh or don't be so
hard on yourself no oh I think it's no I
think it doesn't matter I think they
both make sense I think they both make
sense me too oh I love what we all agree
how so okay are you ready for the next
story it's about a woman who we used to
talk about a lot let's play a game
oh yeah guess the story it's about a
woman who we used to talk about a lot
who's very much you know a auntie would
say like a plus plus list forever we
haven't talked about her in a while
oh my gosh she's always in the news no
British peeress know where I carry no I
don't know a plus plus lists forever
JLo no I think bigger think big cheer we
used to talk about her all the time who
she has that sparkle never being Marco
you're doing that song from life-size
cute okay we're talking about Megan
Marco
Megan Marco is in talks with Vogue to
have a regular column in both the
magazine's US and UK editions focusing
on her charity work after a mild Clooney
encouraged the Duchess Duchess to
promote her philanthropy projects that
was a mouthful
Megan Mar closing discussions with vogue
editor-in-chief about writing a regular
column focusing on her charity work for
the magazine the monthly feature would
be similar to the article being put
together to accompany her upcoming photo
shoot for the September issue in the UK
oh she's doing the September issue in
the UK
interesting factoid yeah I mean this is
such a great idea like so she can't be
like photographed in vogue every month
cuz then that's just like tacky like a
column is so elevated it's so
prestigious I like the idea of doing it
American UK she's really a blogger at
her core right teacher what was that
blog she had called um
Lavinia Sarita yeah Tati I forgot to do
know it was a real turd it wasn't it was
looked up oh wait it was I've never sold
to a it stood for like the it girl
tick tick tick tick tick the tick that's
the tick which made no sense cuz it was
the it girl
thank you wait I always like I'd like to
think about like let's see ten years ago
Megan Margo got the opportunities you
have a column at Vogue like she would
have literally chopped off her right arm
for the opportunity you know yeah and
now it's just like being served on a
silver platter along with like some fish
and chips you know and it's like can she
be bothered who do you thinks gonna be
on the US September issue of Vogue
um the ariana grande as of today is on
this month's issue
month is it her pup right now we're in
July so she's on the August issue he was
in the last one so Beyonce remember I
think was historic what yeah that sounds
about right
follow us here last year times its time
flies I don't know how so listen came on
it recently and it was like a big deal
cuz the American Vogue yeah but we're
talking about
no that was American she was on the
cover of W one of those oh no nice w Kim
when she had the wet look oh yeah was
that that wasn't bizarre what was it was
September yeah but no that was like it
was ready yeah no no no whatever let's
listen get me because me Taylor Swift
oh you throw my guy I mean like I would
die and did she look a good relation
with toys you found the chair of the met
calyx if you go this year well it cuz it
wasn't hurt her year she but she should
go every year
like it's an item I mean of course I
guess she can like go whenever she wants
and she wasn't having like any negative
press back then no she's mad she didn't
want to see her hiding everywhere she
stepped off a plane with the Haim girls
covered by an umbrella like literally
like this and then she's in Brooklyn now
for the prime day concert and she went
to her so yesterday and they literally
had like a huge partition built just so
she could walk from her car on the
sidewalk like to the door do you think
that's because of everything going on or
she's just being private still because
for a while she was being thirsty as
hell and now it's died down I think it's
both I think she wouldn't have built
this [ __ ] a partition just to walk on
the sidewalk but she still would have
like on the plane had that umbrella cuz
like she doesn't like to be seen on her
plane yeah I
understand that but soon all in all
where did we land we didn't we did our
thing and I know that we did it actually
I feel good about where we we landed but
where did society lands like our
majority on Taylor side I don't think
there was a major like swing like anyone
decided anything and I can only speak
for myself and I'm at peace with where
I'm at and I love Taylor and I support
her always and that's where I'm at no
and I I feel good about that for you I
just I'm wondering if overall it was
good for her brand or bad it was very
good then it went too bad it might be
back at Gooding and his own released a
playlist that they claim is Amazon music
did it's her setlist and the last song
is mean which is like her song you know
about like many people so like maybe
she's not over it she she's definitely
not over it but I'm just wondering
overall what did she net in terms of
like I don't know favorability amongst
the masses where you see very
preoccupied today just you did some
homework what are you doing over there
she's working for her second job she's a
hustler and she's an influencer sorry
I know I might find myself being heavily
influenced by Marta wash I like all the
time heavily thanks guys look I take
your what's your process Margaret
wondering with a brand let's say they
pitch to someone pitches it to you and
if it's Brad like you wouldn't like you
hadn't really heard of if it's great I
haven't really heard of then I like do
some research because like I'm not about
to put my name on something I don't know
you get to try the products yeah yeah so
what's one of the brand's you've
partnered with that you use the stuff
the most fabletics oh yeah yeah what's
your code for fabletics it's not it was
just a swipe up link at the time but I
Brian
they it'll be coming back so yeah you're
so fab lattic to should be like a
literal yarmulke yeah I am Maddie Maddie
Ziegler did a collection collection like
I need to do a collection yeah we'll get
you there take those follow at Margot's
right yeah yeah that's that's a great
goal for you yeah it's important
technicals it I couldn't agree more
it's important to have goals I still am
working on two major goals I got one oh
sweet sweet
I love accomplishing goals exactly okay
fourth and fifth stories are
his news unfortunately it's predator
news is it's predator time it's predator
season it's predator season and now it's
like whack-a-mole predator season but
the moles are popping back up the judge
is hinting that Kevin Spacey's sex
assault case could get dismissed why
Kevin Spacey's accuser refused to
discuss crucial missing evidence on
Monday as he took the stand for the
first time with prosecutors and the
judge now admitting the case may never
make it to trial
the former busboy who was 18 when he
claimed Spacey sexually assaulted him
took the stand for almost an hour in
nantucket district court for a
preliminary hearing about his missing
iPhone he initially denied deleting the
text and snapchat messages that might
show he consented to the start groping
him in 2016 in the Massachusetts case
isn't that an oxymoron consenting to a
group right no it would just be
consenting period yeah yeah that's not
that's not proper English but he grew
flustered when pressed about
inconsistencies in the phone messages he
gave to the cops then finally pleaded
the fifth to avoid self-incrimination
over what happened to the now missing
phone oh damn this just sounds like a
sleazy lawyer Kevin Spacey liked to have
an advantage of a kid no it's like a
loophole and it's just that's so
frustrating for the entire justice
system and for this person who like had
the bravery to come forward to it should
go through we have to we need a better
lawyer
no we need yet when you took crowdfund
so this guy gets a better lawyer
that's so unbelievably frustrating and
I'm weird but it's all taking place in a
Tucket you know like the office I mean
the the courtroom is like 1 foot wide
yeah yeah I mean the nantucket airport
is literally a closet no it's a bench
like in a parking lot
yeah we open like if it rains your butt
yeah that's so funny like the courthouse
is literally like all windows looking
out of the ocean
yeah beautiful beautiful but this is
really frustrating we like it is but did
you see Bethenny hit yet with mr.
wonderful and and Tucker this weekend
yeah sharks like just being sharks no
but I did hear from the other room this
morning that she was on live with Kelly
and Ryan hmm I didn't have the time to
sit and listen to what she had to say oh
I would like to but she said it's
something important that we need to talk
about that we need to start talking
about so oh I wonder what it is I don't
know I don't know if it was house I
stuff because this week is different
reunion oh yeah yeah and so I don't know
but I feel like it wasn't I feel like I
was probably about be strong yeah Dress
for Success
she's got philanthropic she sure had a
column for Vogue she really shouldn't
yeah she's too busy though no I she's he
a man too and I think she's engaged
Paul yep it's real as hell yeah they
gotta have some Boston Oh today and
apparently I saw a headline for an
article that I didn't click about how
Andy asks her about the timeline between
Dennis Paul and someone else cuz I guess
people were confused and it's like I
wasn't everything I mean I wasn't
confused and kosher to me and if I was
you might ask you know no totally like
please what is the timeline I guess
because it's confusing because her and
Dennis were broken up at the time that
they were also engaged yeah they were
engaged and I guess they broke up and I
think it the minute that he passed away
they were technically not together so it
was all confusing she was sick like I
guess she'll explain it I didn't even
click the link so I'm actually very
excited there's been like a lull in
housewives because wasn't on last week
and like a lot of shows are coming to an
end so I'm just very much looking
forward to this last episode of Beverly
Hills because I I just need to see that
our promo cocktail garden I know uh I
just I need this season to end I need to
move away from it I need to know where
we landed on everything you know like
when the reunions done like you know
what
well Andy stood for a little history
right this season in Beverly Hills and
he stood firm that he will not give Lisa
a one-on-one watch repens i've brooks
style thing because there's one place to
show up to reunion and it's the reunion
and if you don't do it you missed your
opportunity which I love I know she did
so much special treatment know and
that's that's that bodes well for us but
I just hope that the women they can
shoot themselves in the foot if they
spend too much time talking about least
I sound too bitter like because the Lisa
stands like the argument they make is
like these women you know ganging up on
her and like they're obsessed with her
she's the only thing that's interesting
about the show so we used to gotta
circumvent agreed okay but just as her
Kevin Spacey's accuser justice for Kevin
Spacey's accuser like pray for a legal
miracle I don't know what those look
like but you need one
we need a full court miracle right now
we do need the full court miracle okay
the final story is the full Jeffrey
Epstein story we talked about it a
little bit yesterday
now we're getting into the facts because
this is the Big Kahuna this is the big
fish of predators it's so crazy like if
you read blinds or if you just see most
people don't know who Geoffrey Epson in
this is not like famous he's just like
wealthy and and connected connected but
he is the link between so many people
like and his his Reach is so far and so
wide it even comes back to the
housewives yeah and he's really like the
facilitator for so much more predatory
behavior but he's like a a predator
concierge like he'll bring young boys
and girls to predators yeah this would
be like cutting off the head of the
snake right you know a bunch of other
heads might pop up but this was a big
one Jeffrey Epstein charged with sex
trafficking victims as young as 14
Epstein 66 is accused of seeking out
minors summons and his 14 from at least
2002 through 2005 and paying them
hundreds of dollars in cash for sex
that's a quote a bash trove of loot
photographers of young looking women or
girls was canvassed of lewd photographs
it was confiscated from the New York
City home of Jeffrey Epstein
federal prosecutors revealed Monday
after a newly unsealed indictment
accused the multi-millionaire financière
of exploiting a vast network of underage
victims for sex Epstein is accused of
seeking out minors some as young as 14
from 2005 2002 to 2005 and paying them
hundreds of dollars in cash for sex at
either his Manhattan townhouse or his
estate in Palm Beach Florida he's being
charged with one count of sex
trafficking conspiracy and one count of
sex trafficking he faces up to 45 years
in prison if found guilty during a
federal court appearance Monday
afternoon in Manhattan I've seen where a
blue jumpsuit and pleaded not guilty to
the charges against him federal
prosecutor Alex Ross Miller in arguing
against granting him bail told the judge
that Epstein is quote extraordinarily
wealthy and a flight risk because he has
the means to flee he also accused
obscene of witness intimidation
including horsing off the road a father
of one of the victims oh yeah this is so
crazy so I'm really hoping could they
give him Billy its jury's still out
literally literally um we don't know yet
that's who said but it's the dad okay I
don't know if he wasn't then it'd be
murder
what a [ __ ] monster I cannot wait for
the reckoning of Jeffrey Epstein and I'm
excited to see like who we dragged down
with him cuz like I'm just excited to
see what other celebrities and like
notable people are animals as well but
like he is really the purveyor of so
much evil that I can't and the
housewives connection which auntie's has
been saying for years Django are all
over this if you guys want to know like
more about these stories go to and the
stuff that people can't write without
you know maybe being founder and right
go to empty and John Doe the sweaters so
he has like this cons he is like an
assistant basically who's the purveyor
of his underage girls like it's her job
to like go find facilitate and she's
very good friends this facilitator with
Carol Roswell which is like what like so
weird yeah I think he calls her the
recruiter yeah that's perfect word yes
it's crazy no this whole thing is like
so disgusting so vile like I'm just so
upset it's like men in these positions
like somehow always come out on the
other side clean like you know what I
mean yeah and he's been on trial for
this before and it was like completely
Bob oh really yeah he got 13 months in
prison I mean I guess he did go to jail
but like no the punishment did not fit
the crime so they're saying this is like
the do-over and I think everyone wants
to get it right but it's an
all-hands-on-deck it's like if they had
another opportunity to get our Kelly
like they're all going for it right you
know it's it it's your time time's up
someone is saying in the comments and
they don't know if it's true that there
is a connection between Cameron voice
and Jeffrey Epstein
know what I'm just saying Sadie Sanchez
say what did she say that there's a
connection time and we just search their
names together they might just be in
like headlines of the day together
that's true yeah no I don't believe that
Cameron was is pure oh so yeah but
Jeffery Epstein's not also I saw an
article on e today that there look
they're doing further investigation into
Cameron voices death are they yeah well
it is untimely and odd so yeah no I
think and any twenty-year-old dies
deserves a she deserves an investigation
here I'll click that article Cameron
Boyce is cause of death under further
investigation as autopsy is completed
they
friends and fans are in mourning of
following the death of Cameron Boyce the
blood Disney Channel star who appeared
in descendants as well as Jessie passed
away on July 6 an autopsy was performed
on Monday and a cause of death was
deferred pending further investigation
that's interesting
that's filing an autopsy yeah maybe just
so many things are happening like
remember when Anthony Bourdain died and
like so many there was a beach it was
all like in the same month it's so
creepy but like all these things happen
at the same time it's generally like
Illuminati season yeah also when it
rains it pours yeah
in a bad way too yeah yeah in a bad way
too also we are doing our empty blinds
episode this week so if you want to know
more about blind items and people who
commit these vicious felonies had over
to patreon.com slash the morning coast
done okay you look nice today thank you
was that uh yeah I just felt like that
yeah I know but it's like I'm all aware
of like boobs now because I've been
wearing a new bra that like chili
changed my life like I don't know if you
guys can see cuz I'm wearing oversized
sherry now but like my boobs are not
touching and I literally can't tell you
the last time my breasts didn't touch
each other that's really exciting that's
it fair enough
of course cuz I took the perfect fit
panda quiz Margot's we're going at you I
actually took the Fit Fighter 2 quiz
twice because I was so hell-bent on
getting the absolute perfect size I'm a
little embarrassed to say my size so I'm
not gonna say because it's really
[ __ ] big but at least there's a bra
for me like I've literally never walked
into a store be like okay you're sorry
yeah I can't no I'm at an off-the-rack
kind of gal you know but they're love
it's so easy and it comes I got also
strapless bras because to hold these Big
Kahuna's up is not easy
third love is a partner of the show but
they're also like a brand that truly
changed my life like in the most
positive way yes go online take their
fit finder quiz to answer a few simple
questions to find your perfect fit in 60
seconds they have a hundred percent fit
guarantee they have comfort they've
quality returns and exchanges are free
and easy and they have a fit stylist
that is available every day to help be a
text chat or phone it's really premium
third love knows there's a perfect bra
for everyone I honestly didn't know that
until I found third love um so right now
they're offering our listeners 15% off
your first order go to 3rd love.com
slash
morning toast now to found to find your
perfect fitting bra and get 50% off your
first purchase
that's third love.com slash morning
toast for 15% off today I sometimes find
like doing like sponsorships for the
show like to be so easy because like I
[ __ ] love their love
I love away and love function of beauty
no I completely agree and does the best
job of these brands we use before some
of them we were introduced to because
they wanted to partner with our show and
like it changed our lives their love
truly like has changed my back it's
changed my life it's changed the tops
that I wear like it is one of the brands
like I'm so grateful for the choice for
yeah and it's like I'm just so honored
to be advertising for them and like do
you think that we are out of all the
people that partner with third-level we
have the biggest sets I do like combined
Oh honestly yeah yeah we have big jugs
yeah three of us they all have different
kinds of tits and it works right yeah I
feel as though we are experts on the
matter no I mean like like I always say
Joe take a recommendation for like you
know what type of net seat for me you
know but definitely take a
recommendation on bras yeah from all of
us yeah because we're the big titty
committee
we I feel as though I am the host of the
big titty committee you know yeah I I
take the minutes yeah you do you the
secretary mark is the treasurer
yeah I'm the PA but like committee they
need one okay blows yeah I can't believe
you watch below-deck it's like so weird
now that we like recap it I know and I
don't know what for this change but I'm
enjoying it
however this week's episode and nothing
happened absolutely nothing happened it
was like the end of last week's in the
beginning of next week's and I guess
they just needed to fill time there are
a few episodes of season where it's like
the Charter Ed's but the new charter
doesn't begin so like literally nothing
happens yeah I need to talk about the
previous charter because I get a girl I
have to get your thoughts I'm on your
hair yeah on her hair I'm the first time
when she sat down with her ponytail
after like doing it on the boat like
right by the food I was gonna throw up
and then I was like your hair looks
great I'm like your helix dub
what are your thoughts um I mean good on
her for like she doesn't have a record
label or anything like her parents like
paid for a boat like that's nice like
not to have to worry to when you can
bring your videographer your
choreographer and just pay for your own
music video like what a life what a life
it's really fun
she was working on this trip and it's
like you don't need to work like just
enjoy the [ __ ] trip but I guess
that's like us and like making content
yeah it doesn't feel like work at first
when she came on the boat I was like
cringe this is gonna be so cheesy but
I'm not gonna lie by the end like okay
the music the song or in the video like
I did watch the video on YouTube someone
posted the link and like it wasn't great
but I felt like she went about it in
like a really cute way also for someone
who could be like so obnoxious and
cringy she was so polite polite and
gracious and like the whole family I
just felt they had really great manners
and they could have easily been like
obnoxious right now when they came on
you're like oh and this is like a
parents that they want their kid to be
famous they go I'm Bravo like they get
her whenever she yeah rat but I agree
they were actually lovely charter guests
and they were fed like subpar food by
like this fake chef and they didn't care
they'd and they didn't care and they
were so grateful for everything even
just like their delicious hamburgers
like and the cake and when they came out
wearing this like I just thought they
were really nice people and they wasn't
expecting come in either and it was
really like sweet going you know the
next level to they've been put on the
shirts and makeup the dance and I really
like so many of the crew members like
especially the guys and I just thought
that was like a really sweet and I can't
remember anyone's name but I love the
guy who's now helping out in the kitchen
Oh Trevor yeah I like him I don't like
the guy with the long hair who doesn't
work Jack I love ya but he takes himself
like a little too seriously
he's but he's the military yeah he's the
number one guy on deck yeah and by then
it's like a little like who's calling
the one who taught them how to count in
force and he got the anchor stuck
oh and he's like a misfit this season he
said look he's not really getting along
yeah I don't like diver get a little
bridge I didn't like waiting
yeah I'm like it's a little like if he
was the Xiao Shi and it would make more
sense because he takes himself like he's
not he's a little bit more reserved you
I was like fun but also the boss you
know yeah this guy he see he said it
like two episodes I was like I don't
feel like I'm a part of the script like
he was on last charter and he was like
really like in the group and he's like I
like everyone but I don't feel like
we're like this unit yeah but I feel
like everyone else feels as though
they're I love the second Stu who makes
all the sex jokes yeah I love her yeah
she's soap all the shoes are so pretty
and they always get like the most
beautiful stews but she's like so funny
and she's like not confrontational but
she's still interesting do you know any
means yeah and she does her job well and
she's a great asset I'm really enjoying
Hannah when the guys I'm talking about
Hannah on last night's episode but they
say we're talking about her boobs oh
yeah
which was like a little inappropriate
but I just like I I've done a full 180
yeah no I know
that happens on below deck it's like you
watch the show and you see them having
cabin fever and like you get the cabin
fever too yeah and you really go through
like these motions of like hating people
loving people at scene different sides
of people that's like such an
interesting show
it is also captain Lee was being so cute
when she was like whatever it's called
wait I was gonna bring up captain sandy
she is so [ __ ] precious and I have to
say I did not like her in the beginning
because the first installment of a below
Jack that ever came out was with Captain
Lee the guy yeah and he's so strict and
he runs such a tight ship and like if
you [ __ ] up once he sent you on a plane
ticket home and it's like it's a good
vibe to have because you really like you
can kill people on a boat like you
really need to be and when captain sandy
came on I'm like I don't like her and
I'm like everyone's like she's a woman
captain and I'm like she's not doing a
good job being a pushover she's giving
us ladies a bad name I have completely
flipped I think the way that she runs
her boat is perfect she has such respect
for the people that work for her and
they respect her so much back and I
think the way that she rents her boat is
so much better than Captain Lee like
people make mistakes you know
yeah like she wasn't mad when the anchor
chain ended up on the dock like which
captain Lee like you would have been
home before they got big anchor down
like he would have been furious like
that's how you teach someone like with
through like tough love you know yeah no
that's a good point I really like her
like I flipped on her and I think she's
really becoming like an icon in the
Bravo community she was on the pride
float yeah I love her I love her too
next week's episode looks amazing
because we had Jacqueline Segal coming
as a charter guest and if you don't know
who she is she was the star of the
documentary queen of Versailles and you
haven't seen that documentary it's about
something important that you see it saij
have you seen it
no but okay it's about this like super
rich family and they're gonna do a
documentary on this enormous reality of
building the biggest residential America
and don't spoil it
okay fine so something happens during
and documented become ghost movie of the
week the documentary becomes about
something completely different okay
yeah it's the toast movie of the week
now um and she is the Charter guest next
week which is insane and it sounds like
she's being so crazy yeah I know I'm
really looking forward to it I'm really
looking forward to it wow that was to be
interesting charter guests that helps
with making the episodes more interested
charter guests really make the episode
so many times like whether they're
they're cool or not right let you but
you didn't watch but in the low-tech
regular with Captain Lee there's a
charter guest named Dean okay and it's a
Kimmy KHSAA like they have this like
beef because like the first time he was
such a dick that you know they leave
like towel art on their beds and she
made a penis but she's like it's a
rocket ship you know and they had like
this contentious relationship but I
thought yeah well I can everything about
with Hanna is when she was hooking up
with a target right and she just met
Jace and she was running wretches of
Jason I mean she left her text messages
on the iPad that was like probably the
best season ever
I was thinking crazy that was crazy
especially cuz like she should have
gotten fired forever
a hundred percent the Chiefs twos always
get like a free pass because like they
technically have the most difficult job
oh so I was watching and it really is
camp like the crew where the counselors
and the yet harder guests are the
campers and when they were doing that
dance and I'm like this is [ __ ]
camped Oh totally did you watch the last
season with Captain Lee in Tahiti and
Kate Chastain yes um
and wait [ __ ] what was I gonna mention
there cuz I just watched that season but
did you see the last episode with the
Charter guests to the girl and her
friends who were horrific
you have to remind me um it was her
birthday they got fireworks they were
fighting no time and they were all drunk
and it was so embarrassing that's so
funny but no no okay well you know
what's so funny also I was like there
with so many iterations of blow Jack and
so many captains and there was one
captain who's on for one season I guess
Italy didn't like him he was such a nice
guy he was just like looked like a dad
he was like kind of strict but like
quiet he didn't add anything I was what
happened to him he probably just didn't
make for great TV yeah
probably like seeing the success of
captain Lee and captain sandy and like
being jealous totally okay next up we're
gonna indulge some of you snitch how was
the Bachelorette last night oh my god
just give us the synapse
it was infuriating yeah it was it was
hometowns was left for guys lives left
it's Luke P which nobody likes which
what's his vibe his vibe is that he's a
manipulative [ __ ] makes no sense and
like she said something once that like
makes sense me because it makes no sense
while she's keeping him around this long
she's like either he's making me go
crazy or I'm in love with him which like
I get that but it's the wrong decision
whatever then there's Jed who as well
but then there they but should everyone
hate him before yeah he's annoying he's
always kind of saying you know oh no
okay and then maybe when people - then
there's the two precious angels Tyler C
and Peter the pilot the pilot and those
dates were great whatever and so they're
obviously top - no I don't think so I
act I really didn't think I knew who won
like I and also if someone [ __ ]
spoils it for me I'm gonna kill someone
yeah but I really think Jed wins which
is just unbelievable you know I actually
read a spoiler but I can't remember what
it did because no I honestly don't
remember like I wanted to know because
it was infuriating blackness why would
you think he wins if he's annoying well
because she said she told him she was
falling in love with him and she hasn't
said that to Ben Higgins anyway but it
was mad annoying because I figure Jed
must win and they showed a preview last
week of Luke P yelling at her about sex
and the fantasy suite so write that in
there you know then that both of them
make it to pass this so then it's
between Tyler scene Peter how do you
choose when they're both the most
precious right but then it was rose
ceremony and Tyler she and Peter got the
first two roses and everyone was like
what's going on and then she couldn't
make a decision so all [ __ ] four are
going to fantasy suites sex with four
guys without Luke P she probably won't
have sex at all that they lie - like
Raven was here she told us she didn't
have brilliant
yes but apparently like I think next
week during the day date like she has
sex with Jed in the windmill and that's
what causes a stir I thought she already
had sex anyone know that was a preview
for a time that we haven't so I haven't
been watching but apparently she's
having sex we'll have people and like
everyone's like angry she's had sex with
one person she she hasn't had sex yet as
for things that have been previewed that
was a preview oh and that was loopy
yelling at her about having sex in the
windmill how did he find you haven't
seen she cuz he she he was younger he
was like if you have sex with anybody
else here then I'm leaving
he's like my wife wouldn't and she was
like well really I had sex in a windmill
twice ah I don't kill her all right
hadn't happened yet what happens next
week you never took big cheese like the
one good footage minute of footage for
four months they tease it it's torture
I don't feel FOMO from this at all but
I'm happy for you for recapping and the
choice are some wanted it murder you
should want your own bachelor podcast
would you guys be interested in the TNN
show hosted by snitch and maybe someone
else just recapping the bachelor yeah
bachelor that's right and bachelor
paradise would you do that oh do that
I'm gonna watch bachelor in paradise of
course because that's fun and I might be
in China season just to get to know the
people because it's good guys coming out
of it and we have good girls from whose
last bachelor Colton oh yeah Colton
season a lot of people saying the
comments I don't to look now no there's
no was spoiling there is there's a spam
yeah I'm hiding it hold on okay um yeah
we got lots of porn here what would your
bachelorette show call beacon
show be called Clarett honestly I like
that I like you too but it requires
you'd have previous knowledge of snitch
I'm gonna need to blue need to expand
this reckoning rose like it means yeah
yeah I really think that we should do
that okay but who would como so with you
who washes enough yes someone who
watches maybe need like a bachelor
nation person to do it yeah someone in
New York there's a couple oh yeah
that's actually a great idea cool
excited that you're a podcast us now
good now Blanche oh sure are some punch
oh thanks guys
I've got myself being influenced by you
every day what did I do after this okay
can we please over the word char yes
that's really why we're here yeah that's
why I brought my computer today okay so
and I'm gonna place an order
once it's up so everyone the website is
WWF morning toast calm it'll be open
momentarily
you can place as many orders as you want
I'm so nervous
I'm so I'm nervous too I want to get it
me too I don't know why I feel like it's
like missing stuff no I I went through
this morning it's like I'm gonna miss it
if I don't get it but I'm really getting
one of everything
disable password let me know when I can
press ENTER save one second
loading oh we're good we're live I'm
gonna get here's the thing podcast I
mean podcasts pop socket I'm gay it's
not going for me hold on
the password is still on Passport are
you in I'm in Oh No reload I'm in well
so just put in the password flag are you
getting a large and all this in all of
the sweatshirt so you can wear them as
dresses I think so I just love a large
sweatshirt
yeah that's every once in a while I want
like a fitted one maybe I'll have two I
think I'll get the cross to bear as a
fitted one koozies I can't believe oh my
god I have to get the visor and I might
have won a bucket hat I'm definitely
adding a bucket hat also like my kuzey
like I'm just gonna use for like fresca
yeah yeah okay keep going I'm literally
gonna place a $600 order I do want one
of everything you guys did you will
sticker I'm actually gonna get another
just in case I lose my drool that's a
good cause
Oh a morning the cropped East oh my god
I'm excited yeah we got some crop tease
for the thoughts like you should I get a
smaller ski their sweatshirt is of
course oh and here's the thing t-shirt
there's also a sorority sweater that I
don't have you know because there's two
versions oh yes I only have the TMT one
and I need to get the other one is
everyone's shopping till they were
dropping I hope so I hope so and go to
shop all if you want to see everything
that's there because the homepage is all
the new stuff
fanny pack I'm getting the holographic
one so excited I'm excited too I'm just
like I think I'm gonna edit later
should I get the visor or the bucket hat
or both I think I think the guys I
didn't really don't actually see you in
a bucket at what I gotta do you know do
you not know that bucket hat is
American camper oh she needs it if you
want if you're looking for the sorority
sweatshirt go to click bestsellers at
the top yes sure TMT that's I don't have
that one I don't have that one either
that I'll get in a large bow show oh no
excellent lol I got towels how am I
gonna stay dry if I don't get a towel
like lol excellent put a small delete in
my cart ooh
okay now the orders are really good
should call it some people's names to
place orders yeah I don't know what if
someone's like a closet toaster I need
the here's the thing top socket because
my pop socket is ready for Darby Shannon
burger hello Jaime Lorenzo
Natalie Dalton Julia Anderson wow you
guys are so quick yeah I know I'm taking
forever hold on Ramona I think people
planned out okay 1 2 3 6 items I think
that's good
yeah I'm at sixes Oh should I get the
flag or like where am I gonna put it in
my apartment oh my god so he it [ __ ] you
Nicole we're gonna go on like to
Rockport with your friends you guys need
to find the boats how I know what you
stand for knows what I'm saying -
Claudia today like I didn't realize how
much merch I have one of everything that
I was wearing I was a walking
advertisement like I would wear a camp
so sweatshirt asleep and then put my
steen slides on and like it was just
like embarrassing like okay we get it
look at it you're a toaster this is
really what dreams are made of
okay should we log off hold on let me
just place it over okay
what color Cousy did you get I I I'm not
sold on a koozie cause like I got the we
drink beer
no and everyone like was I never knew
koozies were so popular but I actually
don't think okay I gotta cross to bear
sweatshirt I got a crop I got everything
facebait ordering my own merch like I
feel like such a consumer getting high
on your own supply better truly I have
that okay I think I should get a crop
top because you just never know when
you're gonna need a crop
I mean Margaret's needs a crab I know I
had to but I only did one it's a flowy
fit so that sounds great everyone get a
fanny pack yes I got the holographic but
people want to know the best size for
the sorority sweatshirt I personally
wear large that it's like oversized on
me
but you can't go wrong I got an XL they
go up to 2x well I
we're large or extra large in our
sweatshirts it's pretty much the same
yeah
just ones like a little bit longer a
little bit longer and be fine Wow okay
so make sure to have to shop morning
toast comm merch will be up for a
limited time probably in the next one or
two days we'll close the store we know
some of you guys get paid tomorrow so we
will wait but thanks for that
never-ending support we hope you like
your merger once you get it
obviously picture yourself in it we will
be posted on the morning shows Instagram
I want to see those flags out and about
meet you I need like the most premium
content with the flags people [ __ ]
flagpole in your house or something like
I want it at the top yeah if you work at
a school on the flagpole if you have a
boat if you have a pickup truck if
you're tailgating flag pole flagpole
anyways that's all she wrote we love you
thank you for buying the merch and thank
you for watching the morning toast we
will be back tomorrow and I just can't
wait to see you bye
you